for Marvel films to television to parks
the comics we have everything coming to
Marvel in 2020 so far that's right
you're watching are some ideas show and
we are telling you everything coming in
2020 to marvel that we know of so far
yes who knows from film to TV to games
to comics we have got it all all right
you guys how about we kick it off with
Marvel Studios oh yes sir I think we
shall because first up is Marvel Studios
Black Widow natasha has her very own
solo film directed by the amazing Kate
Shortland an incredible cast is being
added in addition to Scarlett Johansson
and have you guys seen the trailer yet
I'm talking tons of spy action I'm
talking a certain character that
Langston likes taskmaster there it is I
cannot wait to see Marvel Studios Black
Widow in theaters on May 1st also coming
up from Marvel Studios Marvel Studios of
the Falcon and the Winter Soldier the
first Marvel Studios original series to
hit the new streaming service Disney
Plus we're gonna have showrunner Malcolm
Spellman I bring us these characters
after the events of Marvel Studios
Avengers endgame and of course we have
Sam Wilson and Bucky Barnes returning
Anthony Mackie and Sebastian Stan but
check this out Wyatt Russell during the
cast as John Walker oh it's gonna be
amazing and you got to check out Marvel
Studios now Falcon and the Winter
Soldier when it debuts on Disney plots
in the fall of 2020 there's even more
action coming from Marvel Studios to the
box office namely Marvel Studios theater
no yeah very cold directed by Chloe's
out it's gonna have an epic all-star
cast I cannot wait to see that trailer
we've seen some of the art already it's
gonna be really cool make sure you stay
tuned so much more to come get ready for
Marvel Studios the Eternals in theaters
November 6 2020 yeah and if you have
Disney Plus already or you don't go
subscribe because you can see Marvel's
hero project it's on right now and it's
gonna be continuing through 2020 this
show is so inspiring it's all about
these heroic kids that are making a
difference in their communities and
Marvel honors them in really awesome
different ways one of which is a comic
book that features them as the hero of
their own story which you can actually
read those at marvel.com slash hero
projects they're super inspiring and in
this world of all worlds don't we
just to feel great yeah a delight how
about this Marvel's storyboards gonna be
12 episode nonfiction original series
following Joe Quesada Marvel
Entertainment executive vice president
and creative director he's gonna be
joined by some special guests talking
about the origins of their Marvel fandom
and their storytelling process and how
they bring stories to life and that's
coming to Disney Plus yeah but we've got
more here yet
for Marvel television this year
including the final season of Marvel's
agents of shield all of our favorite
agents are returning we saw in a new
trailer from d23 and baby there's time
travel so sign me up I can't wait to see
what they do in the season it's gonna be
awesome and it will return to ABC in of
course 2020
okay Ryan Laraine you like spider-man I
do do you like animated series yeah well
Marvel animation has you covered
Marvel's spider-man animated series is
coming with season three and it is
entitled Marvel's spider-man
maximum venom and some of your favorite
characters do be getting venom eyes and
that's been very exciting to see how
animation takes on the tendrils and
tongue and eyes and teeth of venom so
I'm very very excited for that you can
check that out on Disney XD in April of
this year whoo all right you guys we've
talked about animation we've talked
about theatrical stuff TV nonfiction
fiction all that good stuff let's talk
about Marvel games we can't talk about
Marvel games without starting with
Marvel's Avengers big game everybody's
excited for that is releasing this year
it's so cool you got Black Widow Iron
Man Thor Hulk Captain America MS Marvel
yeah come on baby yeah yeah it's really
cool you can have a single-player story
there's gonna be a whole t player
component so we can all play together
it'll factor into everything that's
going on it's coming so soon may 15 20
20 it's gonna release on PlayStation
Xbox Google stadia and PC pre-order for
early beta access BAM actually is that
Kabam you guys know the awesome game
Marvel contest of Champions created by
Kabam but now we're looking forward to
Marvel realm of Champions it's gonna be
a new game it's a real-time action RPG
where players are transported to battle
world where all heck is breaking loose
and you have to align with a house to
sort of survive so you have all these
cool different houses that you can align
with from
house of iron you can see who that might
be aligned with spider guild patriot
garrison pyramid X and I'll more to come
and your battles all contribute
ultimately to your houses battle world
domination and you can get the game on
the App Store and Google Play
this year you listen to some of the
things we love that video games are they
let's step inside our favorite Marvel
characters skins and armors if you will
because Marvel's Ironman VR is coming to
us and you get to play his Iron Man
you're gonna come face to face with Tony
Stark's iconic allies you're gonna go
blow for blow with your villains like
ghost you are shooting repulsor blasts
you have Friday giving you Intel in your
air it's incredible and you not only
save Stark Industries and the world of
course you are saving Tony Stark himself
mysteries and secrets around so you've
got to check out Marvel's Iron Man V
aren't releasing February 28 2020 on
PlayStation VR no I'm gonna play that at
home mm-hmm what if I wanted to
experience some really cool Marvel
things outside my house why would I go
for that instead of virtual reality you
want to experience reality oh well have
I got a thing for you Disney Parks and
Resorts have lots more stuff coming up
this year happening all over the world
even first off let's kick off big
Avengers campus is slated to open in
2020 at Disney California Adventure Park
I'm so excited for this there's gonna be
a ton of cool attractions and different
things to experience like you can take a
ride in a webslinger vehicle and hang
out with my friend and yours spider-man
you can also have a big fun or maybe
just a little fun at the pin Test
Kitchen there's gonna be a new avengers
headquarters and of course you can have
heroic encounters where you get to meet
all your favorite superheroes like i ran
into captain america and i said hail
hydra and then it didn't go well for me
so i wouldn't recommend that don't do
that
yeah but you guys can look out for
avengers campus coming to Disney
California Adventure Park in you guessed
it this year yes I said I'll see you
want to try a little bit farther we are
in New York now you can go to Paris to
check out Disney's Hotel New York and
see the art of Marvel and this new
swanky hotel promises it's gonna have a
modern art gallery assembling some of
Earth's mighty
artwork this opens in summer of 2020 at
Disneyland Paris but you can start
making your bookings right now so you're
gonna make your bookies right now but
you also need to start reading some new
comics and there's so many new comics
this year we've got spider we got
strange Academy we've got guardians of
the galaxy Savage Avengers Falcon the
Winter Soldier ant-man Gwen Stacy nebula
and so much more I was all in one great
that was Fanta yeah right how about I
tell you a little bit about my friend
for the Thor new series written by
Donnie Cates art by Nick Kline and Matt
Wilson the last year has been really
tough for our pal the Odinson gone
through a lot War of the realms
now there's a little bit of peace but
the black winter is coming
whoa sick not good for him but maybe fun
for us I'm also very much looking
forward to Ironman 2020 if you guys have
been reading Tony Stark Iron Man you
know that title is awesome written by
Dan Slott but now Ironman 2020 is gonna
have Dan Slott and Christos Gage working
with artists Pete woods trouble has been
brewing they're talking about a fight
for artificial intelligence rights and
now a new Ironman is stepping up and hot
take he's not super nice oh I don't know
who you're talking about that's a pun if
you know what we're talking about and
we're gearing up for it oh boy no
picture of you will the world of Marvel
Comics is a giant bucket what we've told
you about just a few drops in the bucket
more comics will be coming from Marvel
in 2020 be announcing them throughout
the year of course stay tuned for all
that from all of our shows that we do
we're gonna tell you all about when we
get excited and if you miss any comics
of course there's Marvel unlimited you
can go check it out at marvel.com slash
unlimited and go to your local comic
shop get yourself some comics this has
been the show all the stuff that's
coming to Marvel in 2020 that we can
tell you about so far you're welcome yes
but of course keep your eyes on Marvel
calm for more cool stuff coming
throughout 2020 what are you guys most
looking forward to happening in 2020
from us here at Marvel is it kittens is
it puppies yes is it movies is it comic
books is it friendship is it enemy ship
you tell us
and hashtag Earth's Mightiest chef so
many choices
you guys this is Marvel your universe so
many choices thanks for watching Earth's
Mightiest oh if you liked this like this
comment subscribe ding the bell you know
what's up yeah and of course watch the
trailer for Marvel Studios Black Widow
and if you want to learn more my my
skull face friend the taskmaster check
out you don't know taskmaster